we got it we gotta we gotta we gotta
keep the focus on cnn my friends oh yeah
check this one out
joe rogan calls cnn's don lemon a dumb
mother
for doubling down on a horse dewormer
narrative saying you can't allow these
you can't allow people to say things
that are absolutely untrue when you have
an effing news organization rogan said
well joe
is punching buddy
don lemon doubled down and claimed that
you did in fact ingest horsteam dewormer
which is a lie
and um you thought that was bad
cnn
triple down
cnn defends joe rogan treatment in fiery
statement eric wemble of the washington
post accurately points out cnn is acting
more like an advocacy group than an
actual news organization he says this
cnn's statement sounds more like the
work of an advocacy group than a
journalism outfit the issue actually
begins and ends the integrity of cnn's
content he says if we take rogan's
prescription claim at face value and cnn
hasn't challenged it the network's
coverage was slanted in some cases and
straight up incorrect than others
here's their quote
cnn says the heart of this debate has
been purposefully confused and
ultimately lost it's never been about
livestock versus human dosage of mectin
the issue is that a powerful voice in
the media who by example and through his
platform so doubt in the proven and
approved science of vaccines while
promoting the use of an unproven
treatment for covet-19 a drug developed
to ward off parasites and farm animals
the only thing cnn did wrong here was
bruise the ego of a popular podcaster
who pushed dangerous conspiracy theories
and risked the lives of millions of
people in doing so joe
sitting before me are two wonderful
lawyers yes
please can we would you
give him some advice on suing the pants
off cnn please please please i mean be
careful what you say about don lemon
because i'm currently suing him for
sexual assault of a bartender dustin
heist wow i mean he is incredibly
accused of the harvey weinstein of uh of
the media wow and uh and he has so far
dodged an evaded responsibility and
accountability we'll see if that happens
come trial in january but joe clearly
has a very good claim i mean this is
repeated libel and they're clearly just
going to accelerate and they're going to
keep doing it and i hope he does take
action i know in the past he's been
reluctant but at some point he has to
for the benefit of everyone else because
if joe rogan sits there and takes it
other people will think they don't have
a fighting chance how would he do it
what would he what would he do hire just
find a lot of contact just file suit and
file
joe has plenty of good lawyers but uh so
all he's gonna do is file a libel suit
file right there in the western district
of texas and in the austin division
where he now resides and file it against
cnn and go after them i mean the
anti-slap statute doesn't apply there so
he doesn't have to worry about fees you
have don lemon
i'm sorry sanjay gupta on his own
podcasting cnn shouldn't have done it
what do they do after that they do it
two more times so i want to say one
thing washington comp washington post
calling cnn uh activist journalism is
the
kettle black but at the very least they
got it right here um but robert someone
in the comments section of our last
highlight said what would his damages be
he hasn't sustained any damages so what
would well i mean that'd be up to the
jury to determine but i mean at a
minimum he could get a factual finding
that cnn lied about and that has value
and utility right out of the gate and
also discovery should be extremely
interesting to how they decided to say
it's horse medicine when a doctor
prescribed it to him when i brought suit
for all the covington kids uh the goal
was to stop and prevent them from
telling these kind of lies because
typically ordinary people can't fight
back joe can fight back and that's why
he should fight back for the people who
cannot fight back joe can write a check
to a law firm and completely forget
about it absolutely and then he'll get
an email saying hey joe here's the
update here's what they said you know
sign off here if you agree here's what
we're going to respond with and i'll go
you got it
i mean it was it was pat and libel they
said that he took something he didn't
take and they knew well it was a lie but
your point was sanjay gupta is even
better
they said he took something he didn't
take their chief medical correspondent
said they are wrong and then they said
it again they shouldn't have done that
joe why didn't you press him i don't
know and then they do this afterwards
that's a come on it's a slam dunk
and then they purport that he's the one
who's in the wrong for being offended by
their libel i mean it's it's nuts sanjay
gupta went on a show and said he they're
yeah we lie we messed up we got this one
wrong and now they're like he they had
him on i mean i don't wanna i don't even
wanna think what they did to him in the
back stage when they brought in sanjay
gupta for that screw-up and now he had
to go on national television and then go
back on what he said on the on the rogan
podcast i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
reveal to you guys see i was i was
actually going to hire joe rogan for one
billion dollars
um but once i found out i took horse
medicine i had to cancel that deal
sorry joe that's a billion dollars in
damages uh well he probably does have
some damages claims because they're
gonna be some people who don't listen to
him and some limitation on his ratings
and given the scale that he's at it
doesn't take long to get to 10 million
plus and we know cnn wrote at least some
sizable check to nicholas sandman when
they were caught lying to him they're
currently facing a major lawsuit from
project veritas for lying about project
veritas and james o'keefe so but rogan
would put them at the most exposure
mostly in the court of public opinion
but financially as well do you guys see
the the netflix thing the netflix
protest yes yes yes so this this guy his
name is vito i think right yeah the
competition yeah they attacked him they
tore a sign apart said he had a weapon
after they said he threw his friend down
on the floor that hit his head well that
was and that was that was this dick
masterson yeah he's a comedian he's a
podcaster he's well known yeah so they
attacked these people the crazy thing
was the ap took a photo of this guy vito
when he was saying something like black
lives matter agree with him and they
said that he was like the aggressor who
was clashing or attacking and because it
was an ap stock photo every outlet that
picked it up shared the same false
caption wow yeah which is liable i mean
that's exactly what the covington kid
knows was well here's my question if uh
uh
if one of these outlets uses an ap
source that says it is are they
responsible yes they are oh every
publisher any single publishers
absolutely every single one you guys
should hit up veto sounds great yeah
exactly well i mean i mean all of them i
mean there's so many credible suits but
i think the utility for rogan is this is
cnn and this is the context of covet
coverage right and this is critical and
essential that they let it let the court
fully determine who told the truth and
who's been lying and that has value to
everybody would there be any relevance
in uh real life damages with people who
listened to this propaganda and say that
they had you know parasites and and they
couldn't you know use it very difficult
now the left has been pursuing those
theories in a wide range of other cases
but
normally that would be too uh distant in
order to get damages the amazing thing
is my underlying belief in all of this
is they didn't run with the dewormer
story because they believed anybody
believed it they wanted to create the
hype so they could go get some people
out there who don't really get good news
to go take dewormer the the veterinary
application not the human so they could
then say look people actually did it
after we spent two weeks hyping it up
well so uh one one thing that was
pointed out by a lot of people which is
a good point is that by cnn coming out
and saying joe rogan took horse paste
and then joe rogan coming out and saying
the medication worked people are going
to believe the tractor supply stuff
and that's cnn's fault
joe also got monoclonal antibodies the
emergency use authorization approved by
the fda
that
ron desantis was trying to get because
they've been using it in florida
seems like that stuff really works and
it's approved treatment well it's what
the biden administration tried to take
away from florida and trump they did
yeah no no but according to ron desantis
he fought against this and this is one
reason why florida's cases are so down
right now as they are you look at the
new york cases they're double that of
florida right now and you see their
policies you see the the what kind of
restrictions they implemented the exact
opposite of what new york did so there's
a
there deserves to be a bigger
conversation about these two different
approaches new york and florida because
it's pretty clear what's happening
talk to your doctor
i gotta wonder is the only missing piece
here uh
a definitive damage because
if if if cnn lies
sanjay gupta says yes joe they lied
i mean that's clear admission right he
said they shouldn't have done it but it
would be the damn you can get a
declaratory judgment like robert
suggested during our last live stream uh
nominal damages
and in reality he's got at least 10
million he could get an expert to say
he's got 10 million damages that's just
realistic because of the scale that he
operates he never actually said that it
was the eye word the ivormectin that
that the horse dewormer that made him
better he never even promoted any of it
he just said this is what i'm all my
doctors gave it to me three days later
he said i feel better my uh you know
test is now showing i'm negative yeah
they never even credited to any one
element of what he was taking was on a
strict regiment of stuff prescribed by a
doctor plus rogan also says that uh they
they changed the way that he looked they
they used the filter to make him look a
lot sicker than he was from his original
instructions
so is there is there a possibility to
even pursue that legally is that is that
an option well that could be pursued and
then you throw in that the fda
piggybacked off of this the fda put out
that fake tweak that gupta was talking
about rogan that was deliberately mis
and this is i'm suing the fda right now
for their bait and switch on what they
did with the vaccine they lie they right
now have military surgeons and military
doctors going in and faking labels to
try to convince people that they're
getting something different than what so
what it is is you have currently the
only thing that's available is the eua
so the emergency use authorized under
the under the law you can't uh force
that there's an informed consent
requirement that's the nuremberg code
put into law so but and what uh the
defense secretary said is the only thing
we're going to require is the approved
the fda biologic licensed one not any of
the eua ones exactly but it's not
available
and if pfizer has said they're not going
to be producing it for months
so some smart soldiers we brought to it
against the fda saying they shouldn't
have licensed uh coma uh kubernates as
long as it was uh unavailable does that
pronounce it
i i don't even know
but it's supposed to be like mrna in
between and then covet at the beginning
and whatever at the end it's like
quasi-exactly i think they make it
confusing uh deliberately completely too
much like co-morbidity which is what i
didn't like yesterday
but here's my question the fda has said
that they are interchangeable in the
same formulation they have and they
haven't so what they said is they said
it's medically interchangeable in ways
that don't impact safety and efficacy
however that's really misleading because
under the eua approvals you do not have
to comply with good manufacturing
policies under the eua policy procedures
you have a whole different liability
you're completely immune everybody's
completely immune right once it shifts
to a
licensed product it has to go through a
different manufacturing process it has
to meet good manufacturing policies it
has to be distributed in a certain way
and it actually is medically different
they claim it won't impact safety and
efficacy but it's mostly speculative and
last but not least it has a whole
different legal liability risk and by
law cannot be compelled and yet what you
have is the defense department
misleading their own soldiers to the
degree they're mislabeling a drug that's
not even available according to the
fda's office and the mainstream media is
running with headlines approved by the
fda safe and effective hundred percent
dr
safe and effective
technically the truth the uh pfizer did
get a vaccine approved by the fda
exactly exactly but they don't tell you
everything else
yeah they would say because it's the
pfizer vaccine people assume the physio
biotech is the exact same exactly so i
read that it said it was it was
interchangeable
medically interchangeable is to safety
and efficacy but even that's misleading
that's why we sued him we swim in the
eastern district of tennessee we're
going to have a hearing in two weeks
about it because what's the what's the
has anything happened uh yeah the
government filed their opposition we
filed our reply the judge is going to
have a hearing first week in november so
what so if the meat is the one lying
though what's your claim like what's oh
no it's the fda lied because the fda
misled everybody they buried in the
footnotes the truth they knew legally
they could not issue a biologic licensed
approval until unless they revoked the
emergency use authorized drugs as
required by law and they chose not to do
so in order to force the mandates on
people in violation of the nuremberg
code
they don't even deny that functionally
they just claim we can't sue they claim
nobody can sue them thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you